[Music]
this is a story about
a continent that grew addicted to
russian oil and gas it became so
dependent on one
supplier a power that then became
hostile
i think it's a story of europe being
blinkered of seeing what it wanted to
see to
keep getting cheap gas at all costs
it's a story too
of just how weak you can be when you
don't control your own energy supplies
what happens when you open up the job of
securing national energy to competition
governments and companies have realized
that they really
are at the mercy
of the kremlin
we are in a gas crisis right now and
it's about to get worse
europe was asleep at the wheel for a war
it never thought would come and now
faces one of its worst energy crisis in
decades
this isn't just a question of russia
saying hey we've got lots of cheap oil
and gas we're going to dominate your
market for you this has been almost a
willful
move by the european union over the
previous decades
it basically has its roots in a
fundamental decision that
gas was going to be the bridge
technology for europe it wants to move
away from the dirtier polluting fossil
fuels such as coal and oil and gas is
seen as that kind of transition fuel
whereby you can burn it and it burns
with less emissions gas produces about
half as much co2 when burned as coal
does and therefore you've got this
greater reliance and this greater shift
towards gas as countries move away from
nuclear in some cases and certainly move
away from coal
and the problem was it presupposed a
very high dependence on russia because
russia was the main supplier of gas to
europe and the eu russia is next door
it produces lots of oil and gas
and it was highly convenient
to rely on that
build more pipelines and become ever
more dependent on those fossil fuel
supplies
there's pipelines that go through
belarus into poland and then germany
that's called the yamau pipeline then
there's 40 billion cubic meters of gas
that flow through ukraine through
several different pipelines also the
turks stream pipeline which goes
underneath the black sea through to
turkey and then from there gas can be
distributed to southeastern europe so
countries like greece north macedonia
bulgaria but the core pipeline is north
stream north stream one in this instance
the largest pipeline running from russia
to europe in normal times the eu imports
156 billion cubic meters of russian gas
a year or did before the war
55 bcm of that so around about a third
of that comes through this absolutely
critical pipeline that runs under the
baltic sea directly between russia and
germany
there was cheap gas piped
from russia
that was providing a solution to a lot
of countries difficulties when it came
to energy policy and what's happened
over decades is that
russia has been able to build
infrastructure that's taken this gas
into europe europe has built an industry
industries that have come to depend on
that cheap supply of russian oil and gas
in the 1990s and before then most energy
and gas
electricity all came
from state monopolies so the
state owned and managed and maintained
these
giant infrastructure networks so you had
these state-owned entities which were
driving the market and governments would
be giving them all the signals about
what to do but as we've seen
liberalization and privatization take
hold in more countries in europe we've
seen a move away to private companies
deciding the best way to secure gas
supplies for the country as a whole you
know but with one eye on profit and
what the market might think is a
rational decision
in terms of what's cheapest for the
consumer
isn't necessarily what's in the best
interest of diversifying supply and
ensuring energy security one of the
problems for europe has been what it's
done with its storage especially the uk
the uk shut down
its main natural gas storage facility
something that would be coming into
great use right now it was decades old
it was in desperate need of
refurbishment and reinvestment to keep
it going the company centrica the owner
of british gas wanted government support
to run it but couldn't get it so they
decided instead they would shut it down
the uk thought that
we would be fine because we have
plentiful sources of uh possible gas
supplies if you've got big pipelines
coming in the supplying ready flows then
why do you need to make your industries
invest in big storage tanks that didn't
seem a need and no one really had the
foresight to think
that putin would weaponize energy to the
extent that he has we've really seen you
know with the liberalization of the gas
markets
the security of supply element has sort
of fallen by the wayside and the storage
in baumgarten in austria in rough in the
uk which was shut down they may have
been coming into use right now and we
have a situation
whereby you could start to have problems
not just in terms of higher prices but
potentially even shortages
[Music]
gazprom
large state-owned russian energy company
also acquired assets it owns gas storage
in germany
in britain it's one of the big suppliers
of gas to business
gas problem as a result we used a
massive degree of control but that
control ultimately ends up back in the
kremlin and so it created this entire
environment where
it turns out
a
key
dominant supplier
with malevolent intent could use that
dominance to exert huge power over
european capitals and the politicians in
them on a few occasions we saw russia
try and use gas supplies to leverage
against ukraine against poland and other
countries
leaving them feeling more vulnerable
take the orange revolution in ukraine
for example at that point
ukraine ousted the programme the leader
put in a more pro-western leader
and a year after that gazprom started
demanding much higher prices for its
energy
ukraine refused and it decided to turn
off the taps it almost seems like
there's this kind of stop [ __ ] that
putin likes to move in order to further
his geopolitical goals
in 2014
there was the invasion of crimea you
would have thought europe would have
done more in the wake of that to
diversify their gas supply in fact in
the decade to 2020 it increased its gas
ports from russia by about 20 percent
and by 2020 it accounted for about 38
of all
europe's gas supplies and in germany
more than half with russian gas flowing
and making a core part of their energy
supplies it makes it more difficult for
countries to push back hard when they
see behavior they might consider to be
egregious but perhaps not quite reaching
the level of full plunge conflict for
example in the sanctions regime gas has
been this sort of sacrosanct element
that the politicians aren't willing to
touch
in a way you could argue that
putin was actually emboldened to
continue to pursue his agenda
in ukraine and if the sanctions had been
stronger then then maybe they would have
acted as more of a deterrent
[Music]
politics was suddenly
part of how putin saw the energy
relationship with europe that he could
use energy to exert his power his
geopolitical power first of all in the
near abroad but now he's also doing with
germany it started
in 2021 around springtime when russia
was fulfilling its contractual
obligations to supply gas to europe but
traders were noticing that it wasn't
supplying above and beyond that and the
volumes of gas that it was supplying
were well down on pre-pandemic levels
the storage sites that gazprom owned in
europe it became clear as winter was
approaching that gazprom was not filling
them we saw some of them just sit there
10 15 full
and european politicians were very slow
to notice this and very slow to respond
russia has been able to
supply less during the kind of shoulder
season months when there's less european
demand
and
ensure that europe enters this phase
with much lower storage than it has in
the past and that has only served to
increase
the stranglehold
that putin has in energy terms over the
european economy right now and european
politicians
[Music]
the relationship has just radically
changed since the wars began immediately
europe started to talk about what they
could do
to make sure that they were not
effectively funding vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine
russia did
generate a very very big income from the
money that european companies paid for
its gas
russia's revenues from oil and gas are
higher than they've ever been i think in
the first 100 days of the ukraine war
and something in the region of 100
billion euros from oil and gas imports
and that was a record there is a
fundamental problem that the more you
squeeze russia the more you push up the
price in global energy markets which
means that russia needs to sell less to
make the same amount of money you know
sanctions can only have so much of an
effect if you're still funding putin's
war chest with your
energy payments
it is clear we need to put an end to
this dependence as soon as possible and
a lot faster than we had foreseen before
this war
europe's vowed to get off russian gas
the eu actually wants to cut its use of
russian gas by two-thirds by the end of
this year and totally by 2027.
now with europe saying we're not going
to buy your gas and our relationship at
least with vladimir putin is unlikely to
ever be the same again the calculus for
russia has arguably changed the physical
supply of russian gas to europe is very
questionable
possibly cut off in some places already
cut off
in mid-june gas prom drastically reduced
the flow of gas through north stream one
by about 60 percent and then it went
under scheduled maintenance which
happens every year and during that
period the pipeline flows dropped to
zero
and the market was generally assuming it
wouldn't go back to 100 after it came
back from maintenance the issue was a
turbine they said that there was a
turbine missing russia was claiming that
a turbine stuck in canada due to western
sanctions wouldn't come back but the
german government said right from the
beginning that that was just a pretext
and that actually
the reason for this big cut in supply
was purely political
it did come back it was reinserted the
pipeline started at lower levels it came
back for a few days at 40
but then putin when he was in tehran
threatened that this pipeline would be
reduced by half and he followed through
on that threat so it went down to 20
but then at the end of august russia
reduced those supplies to zero
[Music]
you do not want to be in an apartment or
a home that cannot be heated because of
a shortage of gas
and governments are deeply worried about
this
so at first russia said that it was a
technical fault that was the reason
behind stopping the flows but then since
then it's said unless the west lift
sanctions the flows won't resume
the european commission had estimated
that if it was an average winter there
would be a shortfall of 30 billion cubic
meters of gas
and so they said if we reduce gas
consumption by 15 which is equivalent to
45 billion cubic meters we'll have more
than enough we can put some in storage
so with the flows of gas going to zero
it's raised the stakes for europe in
this game with russia europe might find
itself very short on gas come winter
they've pushed for every country in
europe to cut their gas demand between
october and march of next year to try
and get through this winter without
having severe problems and they made it
very clear that most of the burden will
fall on industry one country that's
already starting to talk about gas
rationing is germany they've said we are
in a gas crisis they're drawing up plans
now to decide how german industry
will be prioritized you know who gets
the gas when there's a shortage and who
has to shut down any industry that
requires electricity is at stake that's
germany's auto industry that's his
manufacturing industry we're talking
about a massive manufacturing base so
this will potentially plunge
the biggest economy in europe into
crisis
if
there are involuntary curbs to industry
economists are talking about recession
so
industry is the more obvious because it
doesn't affect immediately day-to-day
lifestyles it doesn't mean that people
would be shivering in their homes
but it's
ultimately going to impact all of us
the other options
are to find alternatives for gas where
gas is not critical
in electricity generation for example
why burn gas just now if you can store
it for the winter when you can use it
for heating it'd be better to burn
something else
to produce the pressure and the steam
that powers the turbines that creates
electricity there are countries in
europe that are looking at nuclear
especially in eastern europe
the only area where there has been some
contention is around retiring old
nuclear power plants
germany decided to
shut down all its nuclear power stations
in 2011 after the fukushima disaster in
japan
and it meant that basically by the end
of 2022 ie in a few months time
all of germany's nuclear power stations
would be shut now that may still be the
case but the conversation in germany has
certainly started up about look is there
anything we can do to keep the nuclear
plants open
if we see a complete cut off of russian
gas supplies we may need every bit of
help we can get
at the same time one of the challenges
for this winter in particular is that a
lot of france's nuclear plants are
undergoing servicing i think about half
of their fleet are currently under
maintenance
most of us from the 1980s and now
they're getting cracks in their cooling
towers and when you're relying on
nuclear for about 70 of your energy
that's a big problem and so there aren't
enough reactors around just when europe
needs the most
for the time being in germany they've
reversed the closure of a lot of coal
plants that's happened in the uk as well
bringing back coal plants is a quick fix
it provides energy at a time when energy
prices are soaring but of course it
makes the long-term problem of climate
change much worse
[Music]
it was only a cop 26 that we saw
european countries and
almost all the countries in the world
stand up and say oh we're we're going to
quit coal let's phase down coal let's
put coal behind us we do have language
on coal we have language on phasing down
of unabated coal and i think very many
people will welcome the fact that that
at least has been achieved six months
later we're seeing
germany austria the netherlands even the
uk
saying oh wait we might need to keep
those coal plants burning just a little
bit
longer it's utter hypocrisy it will
really undermine europe's credibility in
any future
debates with developing countries like
india
about their call use it's a real problem
for the the entire
global effort to combat global warming
this provides a great incentive to find
cleaner more renewable
greener sources of energy potentially in
some cases
previously europe was targeting 40
renewable energy by 2030
and just recently the commission
proposed that that be increased to 45
target this is the massive investment in
renewables it's accelerating the
deployment of renewables across the
european union
medium term they want to build more
solar more wind uh generation
they're going to be all kinds of laws
coming through now putting solar panels
on every new building that kind of thing
europe has a pipeline already of
projects that are underway under
construction but
your average wind power project from
conception to
providing power to the grid that takes
about seven years so it's not gonna ride
to the rescue anytime soon money is not
the problem when it comes to renewable
schemes
other things are the problems like
planning processes taking a long time
permitting
and grid infrastructure you can't
connect an offshore wind farm if you
haven't got the wires
and the problem here is that these
projects take years to build
but cutting gas supply from russia
may happen overnight as in fact
putin is just shown by cutting flows
through the nordstrom one pipeline to
germany
in a gas crisis the first thing that
governments and companies have looked to
do is find alternatives ask norway for
more ask algeria and israel azerbaijan
north africa nigeria west africa latin
america australia is another big one and
especially from the united states any
country that connects into europe with a
pipeline or they can bring it in by ship
let's do it a lot of the plans involve
importing more gas through lng liquefied
natural gas which is supercooled gas
that's on a tanker and that can go by
sea so almost anywhere in the world that
has the capacity to turn that liquefied
supply back into gas and put it into a
pipeline network the difficulty is that
not many european countries have these
re-gasification
facilities whereby you can get your
liquefied natural gas in and make it
into gas again
some countries particularly germany
have never moved to build a single lng
terminal until now it's building lng
terminals it's even secured
temporary kind of floating lng terminals
they're called fsru's off the coast
which will receive lng tankers these are
these vessels that can turn lng into gas
supplies that can then be put in the
pipeline network it's distributed
through the country
even that's not straightforward there's
no guarantee
germany will have those in place before
winter really hits this year and the
problem with these is you need a whole
pipeline infrastructure ready there at
the port
to then take that gas inland and if you
don't have that there these projects
take a very long time i mean that's
really one of the main problems that
europe has is the pinch points that are
really all over the continent for
example in spain it has several import
terminals for lng but it can't get that
gas then to other parts of europe
because it likes the pipeline
infrastructure there was a plan to build
a pipeline called midcat that would link
spain to france but that's been stalled
for years both the regulator in spain
and france said look this is this is
just too expensive it's going to put
people's bills up so you know why should
we invest
in this just in case something happens
but now it looks like a no-brainer
[Music]
by and large
most governments are trying to pull
every lever at their disposal but
there's also big global competition for
liquefied natural gas it's lots of
tankers
roaming the world's oceans and they go
where the highest prices are being
offered
historically more seabourn gas in the
form of lng would go to countries like
japan and south korea and china and so
whilst europe is important the actual
drivers of of of gas demand globally
they're based elsewhere
china's
emerging from lockdown energy demand
could come absolutely roaring back
and that would be an added pressure on
competition for liquefied natural gas
just at the time that europe absolutely
doesn't need it it could make things
very very tight indeed
we'll almost certainly see prices
spike higher again
as both sides compete to see who gets
the gas it's not a done deal it's
certainly not a given that europe will
be able to plug the gap with lng from
other sources it looks like plowing into
the coming autumn of 2022 there just
isn't going to be enough gas in europe
full stop
and the problem is if you get a very
very cold winter and putin decides to
completely turn off the tap
then you're going to run right into your
storage reserves and next winter looks
incredibly difficult because how you
then top up those storage reserves
is even more of a challenge
there could in other words be a fairly
long period
i'm talking years here where europe is
facing
very very straightened
circumstances in its energy sectors the
crisis is now
[Music]
you